good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and a happy tuesday
happy met gala recap day hello jax how
are you feeling we have a very daunting
task ahead of us i am feeling up to the
challenge but a little overwhelmed
because there are so many things so many
thoughts that i have like so many things
that i want to say to recap the met gala
it really consumed my night last night
um because you were
occupied so i was like having to like
check to make sure like kim didn't step
out onto the carpet yet
and i wound up like consuming the entire
evening
which
you know there are better ways to spend
an evening no like it was so interesting
i feel like i've never been more excited
for a met gala in my life and maybe
that's why i just felt like slightly let
down by first of all so much of the
fashion was in atrocity and like nobody
good was there like it was did it feel
like the most lackluster like d-list
event like rihanna showed up at the end
and left she just walked the carpet it
went back to her hotel oh really i saw
pete davidson was still bright out he
got out of his car and back to the hotel
like people didn't stay for the party
they didn't even go inside i don't think
rihanna went inside i think pete
davidson went inside but like didn't
stay very long
so interesting okay
yes so much about the fashion which just
it really felt like watching the hunger
games and like these other people in the
capital who like are like effie
um but also the guest list like the
people who weren't there who obviously
were invited because they've been before
the people who weren't there who were
clearly not invited and the people who
were invited like yeah first-timers
so much to discuss so much to discuss
and i want to give a brief disclaimer
before we dive in
because
i'm going to talk [ __ ] about people's
fashion
and i just need a reminder like this is
not an affront to them
a personal attack on them in any way
like joan rivers said it best like
you're making 25 million dollars a
picture i'm allowed to make fun of your
dress so just if you're sensitive and
you think it's mean to make fun of
people's clothes stay the [ __ ] away from
me um i'm so excited to get into it also
really really quickly i watched lularoe
okay i saw your stories and i was
feeling so influenced so last night i
turned it on and i watched five minutes
but i was mentally checked out because i
didn't get to take my daily nap
yesterday and i was like you know what i
should i'm turning this off i'm going to
sleep i'll watch it tomorrow okay i'm
not going to spoil anything for you but
i do want to let you know like i didn't
really feel like it was worth my time it
was so good in the beginning and they
just kept saying like and then it
happened and then and it was like
building up to this moment did you
finish it yeah and like what happened
basically is like they
they became a pyramid scheme and
the documentary also did not do an
amazing job of
describing what's different what makes
an mlm legal but a pyramid scheme
illegal a pyramid scheme is illegal yes
okay and so what makes it illegal is
this little detail that's actually
really really important where like your
business cannot be reliant on making
money by bringing other people into the
company like so basically at the end of
lularoe people were making millions of
dollars and they weren't selling one
pair of ugly leggings like they were
just recruiting people that's a pyramid
scheme and that's why it was so not
sustainable they reached a hundred
thousand recruiters like people all over
and then people couldn't sell anything
there was like five lularoe girls in
their neighborhood and they were like
trying to have parties to sell dresses
and like there were other women in the
neighborhood who had already sold it so
it's not sustainable at that point but
like
i just didn't really feel like it was
that crazy of a story like i was like
maybe i'm just
desensitized because like documentaries
are constantly like [ __ ] crazy like
nothing crazy happened like it was an
mlm like it was a pyramid scheme and
the one interesting thing i thought was
like so they said like over seven no
maybe no way more like i think less than
one percent of recruiters were making a
lot of money
and they had one of these girls who was
the third recruiter at
um lularoe they had her on the
documentary and you could tell she had
this like and she's left the company
because she just didn't agree with like
their principles but she was still
making like six figures when she left
she
she just like felt so guilty because
like they were like juxtaposing her
story with like people who literally had
to claim bankruptcy from going into
lularoe and like she's just one of these
people and that's how pyramid schemes
work like there's a select people who
it's formulated to work for and she was
the third employee there so she was one
of them and then you cut to two other
people who like it literally destroyed
their lives they both got divorced like
it ruined their lives so that was like
interesting but i just didn't think it
was like that
good
as a documentary but lularoe is still in
business that's what's crazy
i have to watch i have to understand
because i don't understand no and
honestly i
don't know if you'll but like i watched
the first five minutes and just the fact
that these two founders have 14 kids
because they have a blended family and
they've adopted a lot of children and
then two of their kids are actually
married in a non
weird one of the adopted kids married
one of the kids from a former marriage
so they're they were never in the house
at the same time like they never were
raised as brother and sister i'm sure
like when they it's weird
it's weird but it's also kind of cute no
it's so disgusting and weird like you're
a freak i thought it was huge no and
then it got me thinking like about
clueless
obviously and i just feel like that
movie would have been just as good if
paul rudd was like you know the dad's
legal aide or something like why did he
have to be the brother right it's just
like
if you can stomach clueless then this
lularoe
story is a love story
it's not i just thought it was like cute
and so interesting them as people i
didn't even i didn't get five minutes
into the yeah but just the fact that
they had this huge family
i just thought was really interesting
but i guess they're trying to set us up
because everybody in the family works
for the company right
yes and it all comes crumbling down and
like the snitch is her nephew which is
like really he sits in the documentary
then it turns out he was running his own
ponzi scheme like it's twisted oh my god
theo would never snitch he's the most
amazing nephew no and honestly the
nephew disrespect was out of control do
you think it's gonna like trigger me
yeah no as an anti-file yourself i don't
know if you could watch it i'm telling
you like it wasn't that good and so
you're saying that the nephew betrayed
his auntie
yeah even though the auntie deserved it
this is a tragic story for me yeah i
just honestly like
i didn't think it was that kind of a
documentary like uh now i know the story
of lularoe it is interesting at one
point they were doing a billion dollars
in sales and they had these like
conventions kelly clarkson performed
katy perry performed and mario lopez was
the first one to perform because they
didn't have enough money in here that he
would do it for like low budget and they
said he literally blew up their business
because think of who's selling mlm
products people women who used to love
saved by the bell right so literally
they had one event everyone got a
picture with mario lopez and literally
the brand
boosted sales like 10x that year that's
hysterical yeah also um noticeably kelly
clarkson was not at the met gala i don't
know if she's ever it's disgusting
it's disgusting it's disgusting like i'm
really [ __ ] sick of the kelly
clarkson slander it's disgusting like no
i imagine that like adam wintour like
looks down on kelly clarkson no i feel
like i i don't even know if a designer's
ever put her name forward
it's true and it's sick no she's
literally america she's in the homes of
millions of americans she's an american
idol she's the voice she's a touring
residency she's a queen and you're gonna
have to defend kelly no it's disgusting
it's disgusting except in the
documentary there was this guy he was
like this guy who worked in customer
service and he had some crazy stories
but he was also like gassing up the
documentary like producer like with his
stories and he was talking about kelly
clarkson and he was like honestly i
can't listen to kelly clarkson anymore
like i'm scarred and it's so sad because
like since you've been gone it's one of
my favorite songs i'm like it's not
kelly's fault that lularoe scammed
millions of americans take
accountability no totally like it was
morocco no i didn't do something that i
shouldn't have done kelly did it to me
right i guess kelly was the last one to
perform and they were already in these
lawsuits so like money that should have
been paid out in settlements did go to
kelly clarkson but like how the [ __ ]
does kelly clarkson is a working woman
you know and what kelly clarkson's
what's supposed to trace the money be a
brand paid her and she performed
it was moronic like it was just
it is actually crazy though and that's
what i was saying yesterday like
it's probably in the history of america
i don't know this for a fact like the
fastest growing brand like they were
they said they were doing 25 growth
every month like crazy crazy crazy and
when you see the product like you will
die it's literally like
leggings from amazon they're so ugly
these patterns that are so chewy it's
the chewiest brand
i saw some of it it's not even chewy
like it's for clowns it's clown maxi
skirts and leggings that's all they made
like and you just couldn't believe like
wow this company's having so much growth
and then you see what they're selling
and it makes no sense interesting then
when you think of like 2013 like
you know this is 2013 yeah and you know
like leggings were becoming pants no it
makes total sense especially because
like now we're all aware of mlms like
you really can't have a successful mlm
like that big because you're limited
into the people who will work for you
because we're all woke on what's going
on in mlms but in 2013 there were no
documentaries there were no tick tock
accounts exposing mlms like oh i can be
a mom and work from home and make more
money than my husband and also
that
formula
is something that's been done especially
like among women for a while we talked
about mary kay yesterday but like even
tupperware parties yeah that's what it
was in the documentary um also like i in
the book that i read which one was it
husband secret where you know celia is
very
big on like she's so successful selling
tupperware and like it's good for her
there was nothing nefarious no
nefariousness no and like i think the
tupperware really helped a lot of women
it made me want to step up my tupperware
game because i never have the right
tupperware but olivia sent me home with
so many leftovers from rosh hashanah
i literally just sold out of tupperware
the best part of going to olivia's house
is not even the leftovers it's the
tupperware that comes in there does she
have i don't know because she just gives
it away she sells tupperware
because she is so much you're a hundred
percent right she should she should i
would buy from her me too
um okay so i just wanted to get into the
lularoe recap because it occupied most
of my day okay cool and we're the whole
show we're really gonna be talking about
the macaulay like pretty much every
story is mecca adjacent so um
like if you're not interested in the met
gala at least we talked about lularoe
yeah
you know what we can for the people um
other than that
pretty uneventful day continued my
documentary rick burns new york i'm
getting into like 1900 you know panic of
1873 tammany hall i never understood
what tammany hall was boss tweed but now
i get it it's crazy like when you care
things start to make sense like
literally you're not even speaking
english to me like you've never heard of
tammany hall
i've heard of tamarin hall
love her iconic television host
anyways so that's been going well
and that said on that i think without
further ado me too like let's
let's address the elephant in the room
you know yes it is time for the fast
life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's
episode of the morning toast is brought
to you by stamps.com are you still going
to the post office and paying full price
for postage well thanks to stamps.com
you don't have to anymore mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters ship
packages and pay less a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
they are bringing the services of usps
and ups right to your door and it's a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small office sending out
invoices a side hustle etsy shop
shipping out orders or you're just
navigating the hybrid work life
stamps.com can handle this all with ease
over a million businesses choose
stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send and you'll get special
discounts with stamps.com like 40 off
post office rates and 66 off ups
shipping rates um it's a no-brainer
saves you time and money so stop wasting
your time going to the post office and
go to stamps.com instead there's no risk
and with promo code toast you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts required just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
toast that's stamps.com promo code toast
stamps.com never go to the post office
again thank you claudia so for the met
gallery cap here's how it's going to go
down we have a article of all of the
looks must-see looks that you need to
see and if you guys want to scroll along
with us we're going to post it to our
instagram story after the episode so you
can just pull that up and you can see
the pictures and we'll go pretty much in
order there's 166 here so we'll be
skipping over you know irrelevant people
irrelevant people for lack of a kinder
term and then claudia and i are going to
share our top picks
and i pretty much have mine but i also
feel like our conversation might
influence me too how i feel about stuff
because i need to talk it all through so
let's just dive in let's dive in okay
first up we have rihanna and asap rocky
they came very late to the red carpet
she is wearing a hide neck wrap number
with more than 260 carats of diamonds by
bulgari and thelma west and he's wearing
a blanket and they're both wearing
lycats and they this was like their
first time stepping out as a couple
yeah i'm not gonna lie like maybe my bar
for rihanna is so incredibly high
because honestly
2018 met gala heavenly bodies where
everyone was influenced by like the pope
like rihanna showed up literally looking
like the pope
that's at the bar for fashion so high
for every met gala until eternity and
that maybe that's why i feel like the
two macales since then i've just felt so
incredibly let down oh i don't even
think that that one is the one that like
her bar is so high but it's also like
the yellow dress the red dress there are
like oh i'm saying for the met gala in
general like i think that yeah heavenly
bodies
and you think that that particular look
no heavenly bodies like that theme that
year okay so i feel like everything
since then i'm just like meh even like
camp like i just didn't feel like it was
a clown show yeah like so
we got some good looks out of it and
some iconic moments but like it was
clowns on the red carpet i just felt
like nobody understood the assignment
you know tonight
honestly ever since come to garcon like
i feel like nobody understands the
assignment okay this assignment was in
america a lexicon of fashion so it's
like a
celebration of american fashion and at
first when i heard it like of course i'm
like okay so you're gonna wear the lady
liberty where's lady liberty like you're
going to wear american flag like wrapped
around your shoulders like what other
way is there to go yeah we're very
literal
right but then i was starting to realize
like no you could you know reference a
period in history you could reference an
iconic look you could reference an
iconic person so honestly
when i was watching the red carpet i
didn't think one person nailed like the
american theme at all but then like on
tick tock people were breaking down like
which looks you know billy eilish was
referencing and kaia gerber and so i get
it now but like i don't know i felt like
it should have been slightly more
obvious it should be slightly more
obvious but it's not not like overt but
like now my criteria for like liking a
look is like okay i need to like it upon
first seeing it even if i don't
understand the reference and then i need
to be hit with a reference that makes me
understand how it applies to the theme
so for
rihanna like i didn't like the look like
they both looked silly i agree i didn't
like the look maybe in a few years i'll
be eating my words yeah
next we have jennifer lopez who is
wearing ralph lauren like a total
yellowstone look
you know rancher
couture yeah honestly like i thought she
nailed the reference nail the reference
not the look yeah like people loved it
and i just thought first of all i don't
think the outfit did anything for her
like that shawl made her look kind of
broad like when she's literally like
this svelte sexy like i don't feel like
it showed off her body in a great way
yeah i hated the hat me too it's so
coaching back to kyle richards take it
off i think if she wasn't wearing the
hat
i would like the look more and also like
the fur
collar it's a lot but like it's extra no
i have to say i think like of all the
looks i loved her reference to the theme
most and for that she gets a lot of
credit well because that is one very
clear way to go with this theme you know
i think a lot of the men reference like
cowboys and she was one of the few women
or maybe only one who did it in that way
and so i'm glad someone did it
i would have done it a little bit
differently yeah i'd give this like a
six out of ten it's good she should have
taken her hat off and thrown it yes i'd
love like a skit on the carpet yes okay
next we have probably one of the most
controversial looks of the evening kim
kardashian in black and siaga covered
from head to toe there's a lot to unpack
here because i think a lot of people are
wondering like is kanye involved in this
like should we like it is kanye involved
or we don't like it you know like okay
here's where
what we know about kanye first of all
the person she was with on the carpet
and with all night who was in a matching
look was not kanye no it was the
designer for balenciaga kanye is now
following him on instagram again and
he's only following people who have
black profile pictures which kim has
which lets me know that they are in the
same team they're in the same team so
this is the kanye approved look which i
think we all knew from seeing it because
he's been wearing this she's been
wearing masks
and
i love kim so much
so so dearly i know this is painting you
i just don't get it okay so i saw a tick
tock okay that i don't know if this was
what kim meant but i thought it was so
such a brilliant interpretation of this
look and i saw what morgan stewart said
and i and i love morgan stuff okay a
morgan stewart i i she had explained it
to me and i posted on my story and
honestly like i think that was just like
fashion hogwash like
you know like it's ugly like let's be
real but somebody made a tick tock are
you okay that's just so funny what's the
word hob wash it was perfect hogwash it
was perfect thanks
um somebody made a tick tock explaining
how they interpreted it and jackie i'm
telling you it changed the whole look
for me tell me
so
literally kim is showing nothing here
but her silhouette
which has had such an influence on
american fashion like how literally the
world dresses
how like literally you can't deny kim's
body and the influence of kim's body on
american fashion like and on everyday
people like
so this person interpreted as like the
only thing showing off here is her body
her silhouette and that's the america
like she her body is america that's what
someone said okay if that's true i
thought it was a good interpretation i
would really like that my only thing is
like kanye's been wearing this look for
a few months like what's with
the covered face and why couldn't she
just have worn then like a literal
cat suit
yeah and why couldn't we see that
beautiful face no like the the face
covering was like
why you're so obsessed with glam and the
ponytail sticking out of the face mask
was giving me seabiscuit vibes like it
looked like a horse's tail yeah
like coming out of the butthole it was
just really bizarre
and like i'm sure it was it was warm
because it was thunderstorming last
night so it was like humid like i'm sure
she was just dying in there and i know
she does it for the fashion but like
we're talking about it so like
everybody's talking about it i but every
time kim wears something that we don't
understand literally in two years like a
watered-down version is on revolve
what is the watered-down revolve version
of this i have no idea like that's just
so i i want to like reserve judgment
because you know kanye is a genius and
they usually are ahead of their time i'm
just not seeing it yet no and i'm not
gonna lie like i was let down because
like of course
i was waiting for kim like kim was
probably the most famous person there
like kylie didn't come i was waiting for
kim yeah where was kim and i also think
like i like your theory i feel like
there are other ways to just be her body
because also like there was a lot of
drapery here not that much body you know
it's not like the arms were um like sort
of like their balloon arms like they're
not a long train it's not skin tight so
like if it was just a body like
i know i know it's something you're
giving me something
um next we have gabrielle union who is
wearing iris van herpen pretty like
nothing crazy but very pretty yeah and i
saw on tick tock who she was referencing
and i can't remember who but it was like
a good reference it was a good reference
have you seen the reference picture
before like did no okay so but i'm not
into early you know 60s fashion like
okay okay fine next we have casey
musgraves who's wearing all ralph lauren
um
and it's disgraceful and she's heavily
disappointing everyone
i don't know how you go from her
moschino barbie moment last year to this
like a turtleneck she looks like she
sells lularoe like it's so she's wearing
like
rain boots
a riding boots okay riding boots
a skirt where the slit looks like it's
not even hemmed like it's
unfinished a belt that literally a
receptionist wore in the early 80s and a
turtleneck from fashion nova
yeah and like the hair is giving me
nothing this whole thing is giving me
absolutely nothing it's obviously like
not even nice enough for the met gala
yeah no it's not even that it's not on
theme or it's not nice enough it's
actually ugly it's bad style and that's
coming from me okay no and it's like not
fancy
i'm sure there's like a reference
somewhere that's doing something but
like she's like an american horse girl i
think
no this is not american horse girl it's
ralph lauren he's so horsey so horsy but
like this isn't horsey to me even i
think it was intended to be horsey well
the horses are insulted and they're
quick i think the horses should be
extremely insulted after last night oh
like the way that some people
interpreted their contribution
contribution to this country i think
this country should be insulted
i agree no this casey musgraves look is
very hard for me to digest especially
because she's now over two this week
like she did not do you know her vma
look would have been cute on this carpet
yeah instead dixie demilia was wearing
it yes and honestly i thought dixie
demilio looked great even though like
the headpiece was a bizarre choice i
thought she looked unbelievably cute and
i'm sure she just wore what she was told
yes and i was really proud of her i
thought she looked so cute i'm sure
she's like gonna get so much hayden now
like that we have a like a window into
the mind of dixie like i'm just like i
hope it's okay because did you see her
after party look no did she just take
the head piece off no she had a whole
other dress and it was [ __ ] sick oh
my god i need to see it but like i'm
sure inside she probably took off her
headpiece yeah she's wearing like the
white gloves and the black mini dress
and her makeup was very like twiggy
it was very american the look well
twiggy is like not an american icon but
i would also say audrey hepburn yeah so
then she's just like breakfast at
tiffany's she's here's breakfast at
tiffany's why didn't anyone do that a
lot of people reference audrey hepburn
right but why not breakfast at tiffany i
don't know i think it's kind of obvious
maybe that was dixie
probably yeah
cute very cute for dixie very cute for
dixie very cute okay next up we have
justin and haley bieber who are really
king and queen of
amer they're a couple you know power
couples at the met gal i would say this
is one of them yeah they are wearing
saint laurent and they look really good
for like a wedding
i think that they look like the classic
american couple they do but with her
especially with her sunglasses that's
like you know gives me that tom cruise
movie vibe yeah no by the way this dress
is literally
gorgeous she's literally stunning i just
felt like it was kind of
a letdown not bad or not bad in any way
just like for me like she's the most
beautiful girl in the world like truly
and i don't know i just felt like she
could have like pushed the
the bars at the right right just the
limit
pushed it a little bit more okay it's
just like a black tie wedding
okay if these people showed up to your
black tie wedding you know what i'm
saying like i'm saying if they went to a
black tie wedding i hear what you're
saying i think they look great
but i agree like didn't like reinvent
fashion no not at all but they look like
super cute and the sunglasses are
actually
they work they're a nice touch yeah but
like the sunglasses and then her hair
just like being blown out she was giving
me like a very casual vibe
but that's like a casual american like i
know look i just think it's the back
gala like put on some eyeliner or
something you know okay i just need to
make out like go yell at someone else
first because everybody else was
discreet i'm getting there i'm getting
there okay next up we have the creme de
la creme that means cream i know a lot
of you watch from new jersey
we have kendall jenner in javanche in a
my fair lady inspired gown i just have
to say like i had truly lost hope and
faith in humanity until this [ __ ]
rolled up like she saved the mecca anna
wintour should be licking kendall's feet
she
is literally
the most gorgeous girl in the whole
world this dress
is a piece of art like this dress should
be in the met gala museum like it's so
spectacular the neck piece it's so
i don't even have a word for it it's
opulent it's glorious it's decadent like
i'm shocked like she is now honestly
going on two years in a row as best
dressed at the mat gala when her and
kylie showed up in those orange and
purple outfits
she's going on two [ __ ] years she
kills it she kills it i agree with
everything that you just said she saved
the night she saved american fashion
literally with this look and what's
crazy is like yes kendall jenner is so
beautiful stunning
and smart smart but it's like your
smarts don't matter on the red carpet
right and i guess you do have say in
what you wear so yeah no
i think a lot of people either like are
best friends with the designer and like
are really involved or like dixie when
you're just excited you just show up to
the fittings and you wear what you wear
okay i'm getting so off track okay
everyone on this red carpet really is
just beautiful and stunning yeah so it's
not that kendall looks amazing because
she's beautiful and stunning because
like everyone there is yeah a supermodel
literally so
it also is to her credit it's not just
because she's kendall jenner super
martial agreed like she
crushed it
crushed like i just want her to know and
i hope she feels good this is like
because we say like it's so easy for
kendall like i'll just do is put on a
dress it's so easy for everyone it's so
easy for and that's what i'm saying
about like haley baldwin yeah she can't
look bad yes so honestly like
i don't know i just feel like i hope
kendall jenner woke up this morning and
was so [ __ ] proud of herself for like
saving the fashion industry like i said
it she saved it like i was watching
these pictures come in and even kim and
i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah and then kendall showed up and blew
my mind and you know i'm not even like
the biggest kendall stan like
she
and you know what like
she gets a lot of [ __ ] like for being a
supermodel because like her family like
you know but this is proof that like
it's not that easy because all these
people showed up and they're gorgeous
and they look fine she's
spectacular-looking she is the moment
she is she is before we move forward can
you throw me that blanket it's freezing
in here yes i gotta stop wearing shorts
like yeah it's 71 degrees i know but
like it's you know with a little chill
plus the ac in here the ac is nuts okay
keep going okay next we have lupita
nyong'o who's wearing versace a denim
versace dress which i just want to say
like i like the dress and i understand
the reference because like american
fashion is denim no it was very this was
a very good look like she looked great
in the dress and i understood like what
they were referencing like
americans like invented denim yes so
great all about she understood the
assignment yep 100
next we have simone biles um in a
crystal encrusted gown that apparently
weighed 88 pounds
see i love some mobiles so i really
would prefer not to talk about this
because
it's really bad like it's actually ugly
yeah i agree and i hate to call like
works of art ugly because of course art
is subjective like somebody could look
at this and think it's beautiful but i
just know for a fact like this is ugly
it's just too much like with the
turtleneck underneath honestly if she
had worn it without the turtleneck and
it was just like this sculptured
silhouette that would have been sick
yeah i don't understand the asos
turtleneck me neither
not even asos but i'm glad that she was
there me too like i hope she had fun
yeah okay next up we have like
one of the best
zoe kravitz wearing saint laurent
okay she is the moment like this is
everything like so gorgeous
so and it's not even that it's so unique
like i feel like there's
this reminds me of like rose mcgowan's i
keep referencing that moment but like a
lot of people wear like chain mail type
of dresses out but this is just i don't
know if it's the way she's carrying
herself and her pose like it's so unique
even though like we've seen something
like this before yeah it's stunning it's
stunning and then when she showed up you
know like with channing tatum who was
wearing like an ill-fitted versace
tuxedo that looked like he was the
father of the groom
i was just like this is a mismatch like
it was just not working for me i'm sorry
and i know we're standing the new couple
we are we are they but they didn't walk
the carpet together because they were a
mismatch in their outfits let's be real
okay i just want to say you and i
fundamentally disagree because i think
some of my worst dressed on my list are
like men mm-hmm and on the one hand like
it's so hard to like be a man and like
fashion like crazy fashion forward and
extra but on the other hand like all you
have to do is wear a nice suit and like
you will look great and where i disagree
it's like if you wear just like a plain
tuxedo like you're so unoriginal and i
hate you i disagree i think the best
reference for men at the met gala is
like harry styles in 2019 with that
black lace floral shirt and like slacks
like it was you want like so all the men
should be wearing
no not all but like i just think there's
a way to be different like even if it's
like a denim jet like kanye's a great
example i know but not everyone is
connie not everyone is happy it's the
met gala what do you what is chad retain
i'm doing at the metcalf it's the met
gala it's like a black tie affair put on
your best tux and go be no it's it's and
go support your leading lady themed
black tie effect okay so where and i
hate when people do not adhere to we're
an american designer and you're on theme
okay versace is not even american
everyone who wore
like a tux like they just all are saying
it's like an old hollywood like glam
reference like oh please that's such an
excuse oh james corden was old hollywood
glam please i didn't even see him no he
wore just like a dad tuxedo that blocked
him out in my vision and it's just like
i'm sorry i expect more
that's just me then okay i'm happy with
a man who shows up in a nice looking
suit looking nice and happy to be there
and respectful of the occasion that
works for me okay how about this like
how about just like a slightly different
suit like it could still be like a
tuxedo but like maybe like you know
i don't know something different like
just a classic bar mitzvah one is so
like
boring no like
it's not bar mitzvah like they don't get
their tuxes
tailored for the bar mitzvah like they
do no if you're a perfect example
rupaul
not when he's in drag when he is in the
work room he's always wearing
epstein parker is the name like really
cool custom tailored suits that are like
different colors but they're all like
suits and tuxedos like perfect
there's a way to do it i'm telling you
even in like a masculine straight way
that some people are going to just be
wearing looking handsome wearing a tux
and that's okay
i just didn't like it they're not going
to be on any lists but they're not going
to be on worcester well honestly that's
not true because channing tatum was
almost on my worst dress list only
because his tuxedo was so ill-fitting
you're you're insane where was the
tailor
next we have olivia rodrigo wearing
saint laurent adorable don't understand
the reference not my best dress by any
means but really just fake respectable
presence a respectable look
okay we need to start moving faster
because there's literally so many oh my
god sorry alicia keys um in a white ball
gown cute white shirt yeah cute that
didn't offend me but also didn't do
anything for me next we have megan fox
um we need to talk about her presence
there she was wearing um a dundis dress
styled by obviously style me maeve and
we need to talk about it all mgk wasn't
there neither was travis and courtney
like i don't understand they walked out
of the carlisle hotel when everyone was
leaving for the met gala and all the
fans and paparazzis were there and they
walked out in regular clothes and like
got into a cab and like went to dinner
or something like that yeah yeah like
wow yeah uh so
also i thought megan and mgk would be
there because like they are you know the
new hot couple but he wasn't even there
so like was it she got invited on her
own accord has she been to the met gala
before no there's like this thing that
megan fox was like blackballed from like
society in 2009 so i think this was like
a really big deal for her yeah um and i
don't understand why mgk wouldn't have
gone he's so like relevant right now
they are this hot couple he has a
concert tonight in
the city i'm going it's at the pier so
like he's here yeah i don't know so he
wasn't invited or i can't imagine he
wouldn't want to go like he went to the
vmas and yeah so same with travis and
courtney but like good for her for
getting invited on her own and not good
for her for those bangs okay they're a
crime against humanity i'm disagreeing
with you at first of course i was like
what in the what but then after seeing
like a lot of like photos of her glam
i love everything from the neck up
and i
like everything less from the neck down
yeah no the neck down it's just like
it's very megan fox but it's kind of
tacky yeah and the glam is very like
old american like that's how women used
to wear that i love the glam i decided i
love the glass the dress is an atrocity
yeah
i mean there were worse dresses yes
there were better ones yeah she could
wear whatever she wanted um
[Music]
so it wasn't like my worst look but not
my best and it definitely has me like
feeling
confused yeah but i love the glam so
much yeah
okay next we have lil nas who was
wearing a three-part versace outfit
so
i love a skit you know he had the big
cape and then they took it off and he
looked like you know at night he was
wearing like this gold armor then he
took off the armor and he was wearing
like a comfortable jumpsuit um i thought
if he had just walked the carpet in the
second outfit it would have been very
cool it was like this night like
gold-plated chest it was very cool i
think i i imagine there's some sort of
reference there that i'm not
understanding so i liked that but the
outfit he ended up walking in this like
sparkly jumpsuit is very you know
vegas showgirl right it's not for me it
works for me like for i like i said i
think it's like you know for the men as
long as you didn't come and what dan
levy wore like you're fine that's true
that's very true no for a man he was
definitely one of the best yeah so it's
like the easiest for them but also the
hardest no no i think it's harder for
men for sure but it's uh
but everything else is easier for them
okay next i'm skipping ahead we have
carrie mulligan who's wearing a barbie
pink bustier gown by valentino i know
that carrie mulligan's like not your
favorite actress no you're yeah no by
the way
i don't mind carrie mulligan you don't
no you're confusing her with like four
other people who i hate like jennifer
goodwin no no i'm not no i don't mind
carrie mulligan she's so cute and she's
married to marcus mumford right okay
where's marcus
yeah he should be there she looks
unbelievably gorgeous she does i love
the look i'm sure there's a reference
that i don't even know she's honestly
giving me like disney princess like
little red riding hood yeah like with
the cape like a skewed on her shoulder
she looks absolutely gorgeous and
stunning yes i agree 10 out of 10. very
much like it love the color
moving on
camila and sean
must discuss
so it's an atrocity and it's honestly
offensive it's really bad separately
no good together even worse as a couple
if you're walking together you have to
reference one another you have to be a
look together it's not enough and if
you're not gonna do that then you have
to walk separately they're both wearing
michael kors so like this was meant to
be together and like i understand sean's
reference in the sense he looks very
like
american like for sure like two belts
whatever like rodeo
sure but as a look he doesn't look that
great
and i'm just not understanding camilla's
look at all it's really bad
i mean
the purple is reminding me of like
selena almost yeah
but i i don't know i'm not understanding
it at all and it's not like it's so
beautiful that i'm okay with not
understanding it if that makes sense i
agree like i completely agree this is uh
honestly like reminds me of like when
china shea wore a crop top to her
wedding
yeah it's a mystery kind of tacky i'm
also like not huge on sequins me neither
but our next but our next girl is
wearing all the sequins and i wouldn't
have said that so we have sierra who is
wearing dundis she is taking the
american theme in a sporty direction she
was wearing like a football inspired
number with the number three which is
her man's number it's perfect with a
little football clutch and
at first it does read like a little bit
campy corny yeah
but i love it it's perfect first of all
the reference like football is america's
sport love it love it love it her
husband being a football player even
better her wearing her husband's number
10 out of 10. she looks great the dress
is beautiful and the theme is knocked
out of the park 10 out of 10. agreed and
i feel like she probably felt so good in
it probably had a great night like
something you have to think about some
of these people who like walk around in
these like katy perry in that hamburger
right and they like first of all you
wait on that line to get your picture
taken and you're just like standing
around in like a literal lamp yeah just
feeling stupid yeah you're in like a
sprinter van like go inside to like the
coolest party but like you are immobile
and you're alone because you can't bring
like a friend or plus one like you're
there by yourself right so i think some
people like are probably feel like
pretty awkward in their dresses and have
kind of an awkward experience and also
depends how many like what celebrity you
are and how many people you know
whatever but then there are some people
you could just tell like are gonna have
the night of their lives and what
they're wearing they feel good they look
good sierra yeah
exactly okay skipping ahead we have lord
in a two-piece ivory look
who lord oh i didn't even see her yeah
she was there
i have to say something and this is
going to offend so many people i do not
get lord and i don't stand and honestly
every time we're talking about the looks
remember no i'm just saying like every
time i see a performance of lord i'm
like wow
so we're all just like being mediocre
now like different jokes for different
folks okay fine i don't understand this
outfit and i really don't care agreed
skipping ahead to billy eilish in oscar
de la renta she was one of the
chair people of the evening committee
yeah so i'm sure her look was heavily
thought through and i think the
reference here is marilyn monroe yes it
is i have to say the dress is beautiful
i hate the hair i think it's like
first of all if it's referencing marilyn
monroe it's not a good reference and i
don't think it flatters her at all
and the hair bothers me so much i find i
found it so distracting but the dress is
beautiful the dress is beautiful all
together from head to toe
i don't love it i
i don't i can't tell you why it's just
not doing anything no for me like the
dress is wearing her she's not wearing
the dress that's true but when you saw
pictures of it like it was spectacular
but then i just feel like when you come
up close like i just
i don't know the hair really threw me
off i thought it was terrible yeah and i
feel like this is a situation it's like
she's not like running or i mean also
it's a big dress so like how much you
know yeah movement are you gonna be
doing but i just the dress is wearing
her 100
um and she said she was inspired by
holiday barbie
i'm oh
not marilyn monroe i don't know i think
there was marilyn monroe for sure
okay we've got to move
and group to natalia bryant we want to
talk about natalia i just thought like
who who dressed her uh
unclear
i think shame on them she looks fun no
it's really it's it's atrocious it's
really bad and i love natalie brian and
i just think like they did her dirty i
think she looks like she was having fun
okay
um okay skipping ahead we have kid
harrington and rose leslie
by the way see he wore a different kind
of tuxedo cute
yeah but was it nice to see them it was
but like honestly like okay machine gun
kelly couldn't be invited but russ
leslie was like she was on one season
like a million years ago that's a good
point like he he is america's sweetheart
like he should be there but like
i thought it was weird that she was
that's true just a thought okay then we
have emily blunt who's wearing mew mew
she looks incredible beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful we have maluma which
i think is a great example of a man
taking the theme in stride he's wearing
versace and is very much influenced by
the american cowboy this is a best
dressed man for sure like it's still
very like masculine and strong but it's
on theme and it's different and the
fringe it's great okay cool
then we have iman who's wearing dolce
gabbana and she looks glorious
for the camp year
i'm not understanding this reference i
would agree
i would agree okay next we have someone
i'm excited to talk about pete davidson
was there and like of course he was
there i don't know if he's ever been
before but like no he hasn't seen him
there made a lot of sense seeing him in
a dress was just like such a trait he
was wearing tom brown and i have to say
like i think he looked amazing
and
he's not like the best dressed for me
because just because there are so many
other more worthy people yes
but i love this and i i wouldn't expect
to see pete davidson you know
in the dress no i and i really just love
how he like dove head into first to the
experience like i'm sure like he could
have been like sir i'd like to wear
pants please but he just let tom dress
him and he looks very cool it's def it's
not my best dress but he looks very good
and i was happy to see him there and i
feel like i mean i saw he got home
pretty early like so i don't know if he
was having fun flirting with the ladies
i don't know he got home early like i
was on twitter she was there margaret
yes she was that is awkward and so was
did he ever date kaya
i get all those skinny brunettes
confused
it's confusing it's confusing
well if he hadn't she's next
okay next we have timothy chalamet who
is another co-chair and even though
timothy charlemagne does nothing for me
on a regular day this outfit did so much
for me he he's one of my male best
dressed this is such a very a really
cool way again not understanding what
we're referencing i just hate the shoes
i know but converse converse and when
you think about it they are so american
they're so american i thought the same
thing like i love everything until the
shoes but like the shoes they were
thought through i guess yeah it's it's a
good it's a little caterwaiter but it's
good i was a big fan it's all i'm a big
fan yeah then we have jennifer hudson
who looks glorious stunning this dress
is gorgeous her body looks amazing i'm
sure it's referencing some
old hollywood look because it's very old
hollywood and it's everything of the
sort and she killed it yeah like someone
who really just you know
came out of nowhere looking like top ten
yeah
okay then we have zoe deutsch in versace
gorgeous like i didn't even recognize
her and you know what i love when
somebody looks different at the because
you know these people they get their
hair and makeup done all the time they
always look gorgeous but she had like a
totally different hairstyle i almost
didn't recognize her her makeup was
different i loved it even though i don't
think it's on theme at all it's gorgeous
um
so then what did you think about
haley steinbelt
oh you know what i only saw a picture of
her this morning and i didn't even
recognize her but she looks cute
yeah i like when people people didn't
like bleach ella from taylor swift but
it was very on theme the theme was like
punk yeah and she looked amazing and she
looked different like that is what this
is like a costume party like you have to
put in effort
yeah and i thought joey looked beautiful
switching over from my ipad that's dead
to the phone and then to the computer
okay skipping ahead
we
have tiana taylor rita where was there
oh my god the bar's so low i didn't even
see brita aura where are you seeing
tiana taylor i skipped ahead
deeply oh um
i mean it's hard to look bad when you
look like that right
but i don't know something about this is
just
it's very um like vmas yeah yeah yeah i
don't know i'm not crazy about it yeah i
agree then we have haley seinfeld we
just talked about i think she does look
irrecognizable
and i think she looks cute i mean i love
the dress i think everybody's like shook
up about the eyebrows i know the makeup
is what's making her look so different
because like no bleach her eyebrows the
time in her eyebrows her nose looks
different
she looks very different but you know
what she understood the assignment like
in many ways she's in a costume she
looks like chloe
kardashian yes
yes okay then we had frank ocean who was
there in prada and he had a
prop of like a robot baby
yeah this is a like where i kind of draw
the line like at my expertise like i
don't understand certain parts of
fashion yeah i'm sure there's like a
brilliant nod here
but personally just not really
understanding the the nod same
okay next we have normani wearing
valentino absolutely gloriously
perfectly done
like the hair the glam the jewels the
dress everything is perfect this dress
compliments her skin tone so well it's
perfect yeah
agreed
okay next we have mary j blige wearing
dundus all the dundas dresses and it's
funny because we spoke about them on the
show yesterday for being like a revolver
yep um endeavor no they they showed up
and they showed out yeah no they're all
like really sexy and beautiful dresses
and mary j blodge is a queen
she is i agree there were a lot of like
just great dresses we also have like
laura harrier who's coming up who like
just looked amazing for a night out on
the town like nothing special or
noteworthy but just gorgeous right like
not a best dress not a worst dress could
have been going to the oscars yeah but
whatever like you know no regrets yeah
suny lee was there she looks so cute no
she doesn't i'm sorry i love suny lee i
mean the outfit's not bad but like it's
just the outfit's bad
i'm sorry the outfit's not good yeah but
like her face is gorgeous and she looks
like she's having fun but like what is
with the ill-fitting crop top and the
skirt made out of cardboard boxes
yeah i don't know i couldn't tell you
yeah chloe feinman i love chloe feinman
and you know she's great for the met
gala it's like a new york event she's a
new york girl she looks old hollywood
glamour like it's not the most creative
but she looks beautiful and she did
understand the theme yeah
i agree like oh and i do feel like old
hollywood glamour would be
an obvious choice you know just like the
flappers right the curly wave and there
wasn't that much of it no and i think
she did it very well yes agreed okay
skipping ahead to serena williams who
was wearing custom gucci
serena williams is one of my heroes you
know
so i'm just gonna sit this one out
okay okay cool yeah no it's just a lot
it's a lot and and none of it goes well
together yeah
yeah not for me
meg the stallion wearing coach
best of old hollywood she like nailed it
the dress is perfect her pose is even
like so marilyn monroe the hair the side
part it's perfect yep i agree love to
see it okay next we have irina shake who
was there with moschino and jeremy scott
i think a lot of people were comparing
like irina's look to kim's look
uh well i was comparing irena's look to
lily reinhardt lily reinhart and lily
reinhardt did it so much better one
because that dress is just so perfect
for like for everything that lily
reinhardt represents and then i read
somewhere that like the dress was very
american because you know all the
flowers were from all 50 states 50
flowers from 50 states
perfect like literal perfection in every
way and i of the two dresses i think
lily reinhardt is better
okay this one looks like a little small
on irina shake which is crazy because
she's tiny i actually really like irina
shakes dress i think that she looks
great um i was expecting moschino to you
know do some red white and blue
we were literally we really didn't get
any of that except for like debbie harry
i don't know if you saw her i didn't she
was wearing what you had in mind you
know like if i if that was me like i
would just bring a flag and be like
jeremy scott like make it a dress yeah
no i hear you
um also irena's hair is
offensive right offensive to you that's
it's really bad yeah i know how you feel
about that hairstyle
okay aza gonzalez who's wearing versace
just looking sickening perfect
can do no wrong but again could be on
any red carpet anywhere in the world not
met gala specific but she looks great
you're 100 right yeah but that's like
that's fine to me um i know we wouldn't
normally talk about russell westbrook
but i just have to say in the
conversation we were having i think that
this is a great way to dress as a man
it's not a black tie it's a blue navy
tux but you have like a cool little
necklace detail it's different and it's
you it's better and i like it too okay
good i'm glad we can agree naomi naomi
osaka who was another one of the night's
co-chairs was wearing louis vuitton and
in the words of luann de lesseps even
louis vuitton makes mistakes thank you
and i'm so sad about this because louis
vuitton is probably my favorite designer
like i've ever went to the met gala i
would want to be designed by louis
vuitton and naomi osaka is just like
coming off of an amazing year and
i don't i actually don't even know where
to begin to unpack what i don't even
know what i'm looking at honestly and
maybe that's again like my limited view
of fashion and like understanding of
like this like art form
maybe i'll ask morgan stewart to explain
because i don't understand well the
reference is that it was inspired by her
american haitian and japanese heritage
so it's like a fusion that's very cool
but unfortunately the dress is still not
beautiful
agreed agreed and i don't think that her
glam team did anything for her either
agreed agreed agreed okay i'm glad we
can agree and i'm sad about it yeah
okay next we have troye sivan i don't
know who he's wearing
um but it's a plunging backless jumpsuit
it's fine it's like not really america
like i don't get the reference yeah and
i don't think it's that cool yeah i
don't love it but then flat
perfect ben platt
i hate
what oh my god i think it's literally
perfect it's it's literally when i saw
it i'm like i know the theme like i know
because it's like it's a denim tuxedo
it's like the american 70s it's so that
70s shows way too on the money for me i
love it and his hair was perfect he
literally hated it oh i thought it was
great
like he did a good job
i just don't like i mean you would never
wear it no no no but like i just but yes
i
i know it just hit me wrong i know i
feel that like it's it's it's unique
yes next we have carly clara carly kloss
i just feel like carly kloss like is
constantly like letting me down like
this is a gorgeous dress and she's a
gorgeous girl but like
i don't know do something different once
in a while like look ugly like something
like it's just too easy for carla claus
and she always just does the bare
minimum in my opinion i agree with that
but this dress is like literally sick
yeah beautiful she looks great again any
red carpet anywhere in the world yeah
okay next we have taylor hill who's
wearing versace looking like an angel
who just fell out of heaven yeah the
picture they're using on people is like
literally the worst picture i saw like
her looking so much better in different
pictures but i agree this blue versace
number is glorious and i can't believe
taylor hill was invited like a lot like
there are a lot of models like there
were so many just models because that's
fashion yeah yeah that's you know like
that they have the models there but i
feel like she had like a
she was like super relevant for a while
and like now she just lives a quiet life
does her business like she's the face of
david yerman i saw her at them right but
i think like some of these designers
like still want models in their clothes
yeah you know some things don't change
sweetie is next i thought this was
beautiful yeah i like that it's actually
it's you know it's a good interpretation
of red white and blue we get the red and
the blue and sparkly
um
beautiful yeah
not my favorite not my favorite but it's
a good look yeah it's a good look
then we have yara shahidi who is in a
josephine baker inspired embroidered
strapless gown all by dior
creme de la creme creme de la creme it's
beautiful
stunning one of the best looks of the
evening i agree putting her on the short
list and then we will figure out between
us you know who is the best justice if
it's top three oh here's debbie harry
next we have zach posen and debbie harry
okay respect for zach posen like
somebody understood the assignment like
okay although this is not like the most
beautiful dress i've ever seen like the
denim the red and white like finally
like that i was expecting a million
debbie harries and i got one
[Laughter]
okay next we have grimes who is in a
dune-inspired
sheer ombre capped iris van
herpen gown with a metallic mask and a
matching sword i don't know i don't know
i don't know what to say here here's the
thing i'm not gonna pretend to
understand it not going to pretend to
understand grimes but like respect to
grimes sure
sure she commits to whatever it is that
she's doing
kris jenner
kris jenner looking
like the classy broad she is yeah like
she was really there on business and she
looks like it
yeah no and i feel like in the past
she's tried to like you know try and
like do the stuff like with the kids and
the wigs and everything and she's silly
yeah silly she's grown up
she's grown up and she looks wonderfully
mature and
on point yeah next we have lily
reinhardt who we discussed as looking
fantastic
then there's cara delevingne in dior
peg the patriarchy
okay i if you say so yeah but also the
outfit is giving very much michaela's
bib
like uh just from a fashion standpoint
yeah
okay next we have someone who just looks
so sickeningly stunning joan smalls
gorgeous loren that's literally like
it's perfect that it is perfect it's a
perfection feeling good about it me too
i'll skip over channing tatum because i
talked about here and i don't want to
hurt you any further lily aldridge is
disappointing in ralph lauren i would
say majorly giving me kmart she's giving
me the reference
but not the fashion it's giving it's
giving kmart yeah
okay next we have cl who is wearing um
an over
a denim overcoat with high-waisted
briefs both alexander wang which
she looks kind of crazy but the
reference is there like it's like the
calvin klein no i know and i wish they
had done it a little bit better because
the undies is giving diaper
and if it was better i think that
it would have been amazing
yeah
okay next we have rosalia who's wearing
like all fringe i didn't even see this
look until right now me neither and
literally like nothing fits her the
boots are enormous
the jacket is swallowing her like where
is the tailor yeah
i agree i'm i don't get it okay we're
gonna skip ahead there's literally so
many looks kaya gerber please it didn't
explain to me the reference it's an
audrey hepburn look i think audrey
hepburn literally or maybe not bianca
jagger oh yes bianca jagger wore the
exact same dress
now the hair is she looks like her
mother here yes the and which is uh not
an inspiration i thought that that was
her reference you know what that would
have been perfect like draw a little
mole wear like a classic cindy crawford
with an old dress from her garage the
hair is terrible the
she's going to a funeral i think this is
atrocious for for literally
for the model of the moment literally
the biggest model right now this is what
you're giving me at the met gala and
where the [ __ ] is jacob lordy are they
dating yeah cute yeah really cute why
wasn't he there he like would be there
he's very in fashion like he does all
these photo shoots and he wears like
really androgynous clothing like he
would have been great okay
i think she looks so stunning she
obviously played it safe but like i
can't believe the word atrocious was
useless i described it i
hate it
hate with the intensity of ten thousand
suns the hair
is the worst part of it and the
waistline is so okay but the hair is
classic no i like male americans i saw
the bianca jagger reference the bianca
jagger hair was everything of the sort
this was nothing of the sort
hey
loathe entirely
entirely
okay skipping ahead next to i think it's
safe to say the worst look of the night
dan levy oh wait let me skip i mean i
would agree with you
um i saw posted on instagram like a
really in-depth explanation of
the look and while i really appreciate
the sentiment that was put into it
there's so many things wrong with this
just as a look
and i'm gonna start with the hair
it's so
greasy looks like there's tar in it like
it's
it's helmet head like the hair is
bothering me
so much i couldn't look at anything else
and
it's just bad it's really bad
and he was like one of the first to come
so you just kept seeing this picture
over and over again like some of these
people who are wearing bad looks like i
didn't even see them until this morning
rosalia you know no but hers wasn't like
that bad but like i don't know just stan
levy just like he was one of the first
to make an impression and it was a
really bad one oh yeah really bad um
okay next
brooklyn beckham and nicole lapel giving
me barbie and ken and it's perfect also
giving me like betty draper don draper
yes and like like that's like the
reference i actually i know it's simple
and i know they didn't like reinvent the
fashion wheel or anything and they're
also just like two models being models
but i think they look amazing i
completely agree
amazing i agreed
like once you say betty draper and like
no not a lot of people went that route
either no
so i think i was glad that they did it
me too
um
okay moving on is who else have we not
spoken about
emma chamberlain
okay and then i have set one more emma
chamberlain was wearing louis vuitton
she was the literal first person there
which by the way if you want to get your
if you want to stand out at the met gala
be the first person there so two things
one she was the first person there
because you know how like a few years
ago liza koshy was the youtuber who went
and she did the red carpet interviews
for vogue yeah that was emma chamberlain
so she had to be there first to
interview everyone oh she did interviews
i didn't even see yes she did the
interviews second you were right there
was a youtube table and derek blastberg
brought nikki tutorials jackie aina
emma chamberlain even though emma
chamberlain was dressed by louis vuitton
so and which brings to our next dressed
addison ray oh we got the youtube table
with derek blasberg we need to talk
about addison's look and then we need to
talk about everyone saying that she
borrowed the dress from courtney because
now it if she went with youtube that
means the designer did not dress her and
then she was asked to show up she was
dressed by luxury law
do you think that was courtney's dress
no but luxury lost her stylist yeah
right she'd afford a dress
so you just think it's a coincidence
yeah and if she borrowed a dress from
courtney which is entirely possible she
wouldn't have given her a dress she
recently worn i'm sure she's a million
dresses she's never worn oh i'm just
assuming that perhaps she borrowed the
dress one was strapless and one was
maybe that maybe they added straps like
maybe they made it for addison i don't
think so okay i was fine with her
borrowing a dress like she gets invited
to fashion's biggest night just happens
to be at the one table that's not
dressing you and she's going to her most
fashionable friend for help yeah and i
think that's like so cute and she like
wants to take it seriously and by the
way i felt the way about her outfit like
was it
earth shattering no but did she fit in
yes and honestly i'm sure that's all she
wanted yeah at first i actually thought
it was photoshop because the hair was so
different
from what we've seen but the more i look
at it the more i love her look so much
it's
it's beautiful she also looks like
margot robbie with her hair
and you know she looked mature
yeah she looked like she belonged there
and i know not everyone loved it and yes
could she have done something crazier
and better yeah of course but i'm sure
she just wanted to like fit in it's a
very scary night i'm sure she was
actually
so happy to have dixie there because
like you don't you really can't talk to
anyone and courtney wasn't there i'm
like what is she gonna go up to kim and
kendall like she met them twice like
i'm right i'm sure they actually like
we're so grateful to have one another
there and so i was really happy that
they both were there yeah and then um
anyone else you want to discuss no but
just really quickly back to emma
chamberlain because we didn't even get
to discuss
her dress was so unbelievably gorgeous
and perfect and her makeup was
killer like she was in my top best
dressed yeah 100 agreed but and then i
don't know if it's just because she got
there so early her dress made such an
impact whereas like the later dresses
when you're seeing them all at once they
just don't like hit you yeah no i agree
like
you get a time slot i heard kendall and
gigi like talking about that like they
got slotted together to walk they were
like so happy about it so you really
don't get to choose when you walk
interesting oh i guess if like you had a
choice i would want to be the first one
there unless i didn't like my outfit yes
i would go at the same time as kim okay
so all in all if you had to give someone
a worse dress let me see i screenshotted
some of my least favorites okay i only
got to
like put pen to paper on two were
stressed okay mine is
very very very sad said with a very
heavy heart but it's casey musk graves
okay it's really bad i didn't put him on
worse dress because like
it was not good it wasn't good
and no it's pretty bad it's really bad
especially when the bar is so high for
her yeah so she she fell far from the
bar
one of my worst was dan levy i just
and especially because he came so early
and i was just like oh no
oh no no no no no
then aoc
oh yeah i mean how moronic read the room
like okay thirty thousand dollar ticket
to go uh in the wealthiest room on earth
right now go ahead go tax them no it was
so stupid and honest like take your
thirty five thousand dollar ticket
donated to the government right not to
some museum or the 250 000 table maybe
you could get your table mates in on it
no also i just it's a general rule of
thumb like i don't like when people put
messages like in a bottle on their
dresses like i don't like that if your
outfit has writing on it
i am not going to like it i agree like
because honestly even if it's like a a
powerful good message like it's so tacky
like just like it's so tacky and it's
like it's so obvious like i don't know
you have something to say say it in a
more artistic way
yeah and then when you get interviewed
on the red carpet you can and they say
well it was the inspiration you can sort
of explain but like to have to write the
words to spell it out for us like i i
hate it every single time me too i
completely agree without fail
okay and then best stress for me is
honestly a no-brainer it is of course
kendall jenner with an honorable mention
to
um zoey kravitz
oh okay best dressed for me was kendall
jenner
and that's two years in a row because i
voted her best at camp oh she was my
number one best which is so crazy and
then my second best dress was enoki eye
we didn't get a chance to talk about her
in the people magazine article i posted
a picture of her to my story she's a
model she just was the moment claude
like everything of the sort everything
you want to see at the met gal i have a
picture on my phone just oh gorgeous
gorgeousness
yeah and then if i had to choose a third
well you don't because we decided on one
oh great yeah you're done i'm done um
honestly i just felt like
all in all so many of the looks were
just like so disappointing but then also
the guest list was so disappointing like
there was no kylie oh my god yeah we
need to talk about the people who were
there and the people who were no lady
gaga no ariana grande
no harry styles no beyonce no taylor
swift
done done this out like it was so
honestly like p-list it was incredibly
b-list i think there were a lot of
people who weren't i mean i understand
probably beyonce that had like she
doesn't go all the time like she has
other things going on but like lady gaga
is a weird one to me she's been oh
selena gomez was just in new york
promoting her tv show she always goes
with coach she always goes you know lady
gaga should be promoting she's doing
house of gucci like
right isn't it yeah why wouldn't she be
doing a gucci moment like to promote the
show cardi b card she just had a baby
okay like literally a week ago i was
just gonna say that too but i didn't
even see
like coming on the red carpet having
just had a baby and like giving us a
hold of giving us like a whole like a
hospital room maternity wing moment
right and like a new respect yeah for
postpartum lizzo
no one was there
no one was there i think who else i was
really surprised wasn't there
considering like ever since they met
exited we thought that they were doing
it to go to the met gala same megan and
harry harry and megan for sure zendaya
wasn't there mm-hmm i thought for sure
harry and megan were going to be there
and honestly like i was wrong me too
otherwise why what was the point yeah
right but i also feel like
this was like the losery met gala no
nobody wants to be associated when maybe
it comes back all the way even though i
do think on the right the only thing
that matters is the red carpet
so and that i think rihanna thought the
same thing when she went took her
picture i didn't even know she didn't go
into the party she might have went in
but she was swift i saw her like coming
from the hotel and coming back from the
hotel literally within an hour
so
i even though like on the inside maybe
it wasn't the same as it's usually been
or whatever like
it was still the 2021 met gala right
it was and it was nothing
it was it was really lackluster
okay now we're going to get into some
stories mostly met gala adjacent the
first big one who was making news as the
carpet was starting was nicki minaj who
skipped the gala over the vaccine
mandate and made a claim of impotence
about her cousin's friend right so she
tweeted they want you to get vaccinated
for the met if i get vaccinated it won't
be for the met it'll be once i feel i've
done enough research i'm working on that
now in the meantime my loves be safe
wear the mask with two strings that
grips your head and face not that loose
one so honestly like
i had heard like whispers that certain
people who weren't attending were
because they were not vaccinated and
then nicki minaj just kind of confirmed
that for me and now i'm just like
everyone who wasn't there i'm like well
is it because you're not vaccinated or
because like you were busy right you
know i'm sure we'll never know i'm sure
it's both it's a mix of both yeah and we
knew that the met gal was going to be
like vaccine mandate did we i'm pretty
sure i had read this like page six
article a few weeks ago that was like
all about the rules for this met gala
but also i thought it also meant masks
on the carpet but it's just masks and
they had to wear masks inside
maybe that's why people didn't want to
stay like they were eating or drinking
but they're also all vaccinated also the
food was vegan so like no one was eating
i saw a picture of the food kiki palmer
doing the lord's work it was actual like
rations like it was atrocious i haven't
seen anything from inside yet no like
kiki palmer was like this is why no one
shows you the food like it was actual
like mouse droppings like it was so
offensive to me as a food eater oh my
god and they're probably all so hungry
it's the longest day ever they've been
like waiting on those lines i'm telling
you like the mechala is not working and
like when i saw that courtney just went
to polo bar with her man like in the co
and there by the fireplace i was like
casually that is an evening to me no 100
and that's why i feel like so many
people like they just go and they they
change so quickly into their after party
looks and like that's the after parties
like they're always serving and like
especially i'm sure rihanna's like they
always have like a shake shack
sponsorship like that after party is i
think why people put up with the torture
and of course the pictures and like you
are just you know you're
that's like the highest
level of celebrity i think you know yeah
totally but um i didn't really see much
about the after party maybe it was like
a phone no phones event yeah i haven't
seen i mean i also had a very busy
morning i sliced my finger open which is
why i'm wearing this band-aid what are
we eating i was eating a bagel
because i'm a big woman did you get
blood on the baby no you know no i
didn't but it ruined my whole morning
because then i i couldn't i i was
gushing blood i'm still like foraging
ahead with one hand trying to make a
bagel and then i had to go and do my
makeup and i left it in the toaster so i
toasted it again it was a hockey puck by
the time i ate this goddamn bagel i
didn't even eat the whole thing
you guys just
it's just so difficult it's so hard um
okay anything else
you want to say about the met gala
no all in all like overall it was an
enormous wave of disappointment like
and i was maybe i was just expecting too
much from like my favorite peeps you
know i think for me the bar was very low
as were the results as were the results
so i wasn't expecting anything that i
didn't get i think maybe especially in
the beginning of the night i was like
this is worse than i could have imagined
um we didn't really get iconic red
carpet moments like why did jayla not
walk with the carpet with ben oh yeah
instead they were only together on the
inside where they wore a mask while they
kissed which is the most disgusting
thing
you know it's moronic um also bill de
blasio was there like and and honestly
after that i was out
so offensive no that's actually
disgusting like seriously like this is a
new york event and you are going to
literally invite the man who
single-handedly destroyed the city
and we all agree like it's not a
political thing we all agree that bill
de blasio is an actual
maniac and we're inviting him like why
are we rewarding him
that was a huge huge mistake yeah and
that was really offensive to me as a new
yorker i completely agree
um
and anyone else that
you just
i do wish we could see what kylie was
going to wear and i know he's going to
go with i know
like a pregnant moment
some of the best like most iconic looks
on the red carpet are pregnant moments
like remembering cardi b was wearing
like an actual cathedral and she was
pregnant like a pregnant
met gala moment is
beautiful yeah
why are you looking at me like that
no i'm not what you were just trying to
think like look at me like so terse no
no i'm sorry if there was like anything
else like we didn't get the you know
couple moment between
me and kelly we didn't get channing team
and zoe kravitz we didn't get travis and
courtney we didn't get jen and ben
together no
so
and we didn't get like any real
a-listers like
and we didn't get like any like great
iconic photos like even like when you
know all the kardashians were there with
their husbands and boyfriends and like
for camp and they were just like all
together on the carpet like so cute yeah
nothing like that no
it was
honestly like
i'm holding out for the next monday in
may like maybe this was just like a
temporary event like
they had to have one right but they had
all the same things that the other ones
have
it was just so like
wow yeah maybe they need to start
televising it okay
i mean the carpet was on e no like the
event like
oh my god the carpet was on e and like
all i want to see is like a camera live
stream on the carpet that's all i want
to see and they kept going to the four
talking heads
oh my god i
i was like what am i why am i looking at
those people so [ __ ] annoying when
like the the biggest night in fashion is
underway and you keep cutting back i
don't even care if you know it's
someone's train holder who's walking
through i want to see it by the way they
really need to bring back fashion please
and it needs to be morgan stewart's show
yeah like i was thinking that the other
day because i was like what i was
wanting to watch something this morning
while i got ready for the toast like
hear what other people thought about the
fashion like there's nothing on and i'm
like why can't we do
first of all fashion police was the best
show on television and i do think we
could recreate it like i actually think
morgan would be so good at it i know but
she has so much on her plate i know she
needs to leave behind nightly pop but i
think she loves nightly and fashion
police would be once a week maybe less
maybe just after like big events okay
you should talk to her but i don't think
she sees it like that okay but like she
is honestly one of the most fashionable
people of our generation and funny
[ __ ] head so i think that like really
e is
constantly turning out pieces of [ __ ]
like celebrity game face like it's
constant
we need it's time okay
thank you plea
let's get into our next story which is
brought to you
by bruce and you know i heard everyone
at the met gala was fresh breath because
of their bruce but you didn't hear that
for me the best electric toothbrush on
the market that is also the most
affordable because some electric
toothbrushes can cost over 200 which i'm
sorry is an insane amount of money to
spend on a toothbrush but the brush is
much more affordable and it's so much
better because it comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and i hear the fall
colors are about to drop so like i'm
just saying
don't knock it till you try it bruce is
everything of the sort and it's the
unofficial official brush of the morning
toast the brush itself comes with six
unique modes to customize your brushing
experience the battery life lasts four
weeks it comes with a magnetic charging
stand and a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again bruce will ship you a new
replacement head every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head the design is super sleek it
has a modern aesthetically pleasing
design and it comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter get 15 off your
brush toothbrush kit and the refill plan
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15 off using promo code
toast at brush.com
thank you claudia it's a pleasure next
up we have some happy couple news kate
hudson is engaged to danny fujikawa
after five years of dating wow that
means we're doing this show for a long
time because
i feel like we announced that they were
dating on a podcast probably was five
years ago honestly like i love kate
hudson but i really don't find myself
keeping up with her love life only
because she doesn't really date like
super famous people so like happy for
her i think that's good and danny
fujikawa is the stepbrother of the
foster sisters
because they were commenting aaron
commented finally we're officially
sisters sarah wrote whoa it's official
um that must be so fun for them because
they are i do associate all of them with
each other well they're like this group
like they're a clique in hollywood of
like blonde women who are always
together like kate hudson and the
fosters are really close so this is
actually so cute like you know
someone marries your brother like that's
your sister yeah and that's super cute
they seem like they've been a happy
couple for a while so why not take the
next step also kate hudson was at the
met gala last night did we talk about
her outfit no it was just like a pink
crop top and it was fine it was fine um
also
i always feel like you know kate hudson
and matthew mcconaughey like we're
supposed to end up together yeah that's
like jennifer lawrence and bradley
cooper yeah
but i don't feel that way about jennifer
lawrence and bradley cooper anymore i
feel like he's kind of ryan gosling and
rachel mcadams yes
yeah
it's like cameron diaz and jason siegel
oh yeah
that's what everyone says right well i'm
happy for kate hudson that's actually
i'm actually happier for like aaron and
sarah like that's rocks i'm happy for
the whole
crew you know
the group that'll be fun wedding bridal
party totally they actually have like
that like i feel like one of paltrow's
in that crew
um jenn meyer jewelry isn't that crew
just like rich blonde women
happy for them same fifth and final
story i even i lost count of what was
what in the first story is i think this
is four it's just the last tab i have
open it's like the third story was about
like chatting tatum zoey crap it's like
going but we already covered it but not
being together okay so i brought it up
again but i didn't number it it's okay
fifth and final story you know what you
guys i think we all need this after
having to talk about fashion hog wash
all morning it's the final story
[Music]
down
[Music]
okay do is like stop shut the [ __ ] up
you annoying [ __ ] okay what's
your favorite talentless annoyance
hacks with your obnoxious voices you say
like too much okay all right
stops you're offending me now
okay the phys and final story is that
harry styles and florence
pew make out
pug she's a pogue
pug her make out and don't worry darling
teaser the movie directed by olivia
wilde that has brought this couple
together while he's making out with
another lady that's where olivia wilde
is holding the camera while olivia
wilde's posting the trailer on her
instagram like it's weird but also the
scene of the making out was like very
sexy and like the harry sands like were
there like were not well like check on
your local harry stan because it was
just like this very erotic scene of them
in the trailer i mean only
only harry styles can make the most
boring 11 second trailer like worldwide
news
um and you know i have to say something
and maybe i'm showing my age here but
like i have no idea who florence
is she's from little women which is
obviously why you don't know her and she
dates zach brass i know that which is
weird because like isn't he 1 000 years
old yes and so i think when
they started she's 25 and he's
definitely like can you google his 30s
hold on
but she's from other stuff too hold on i
know she's she just has like a crazy ass
fan base
he's 46. wow but she's 25. she's old
enough to make her own decisions it's
fully formed yeah no that's just like
gross but
but they but you have to make out with
harry styles they've been together for a
long time so like people don't question
it and that's just like not something
people are like we'll let you question
okay she was in black widow little women
midsummer lady macbeth like no movies
i've ever seen so that's why she was in
fighting with my family which i've seen
you know that's the one about paige from
wwe
oh yeah and how she like would fight
with her family in a you know physical
wedding sort of way was she the lead she
then she did great in that film yeah i
just like don't know her but she's super
pretty and she's all over my tick tock
just because like she has this crazy ass
fanbase especially now that she's in
this movie i'm sure like she's getting
death threats for making out with harry
styles but
i very much intend to see this movie
um
but i did see dunkirk and it was not
good
but i don't think that you it that
wasn't about harry for you like that was
about the story of dunkirk no it was
about harry he wasn't good so you liked
the movie
no the whole thing was bad and also like
i couldn't hear anything it was it was
honestly like like war movies are really
difficult especially those that are just
like embroiled in battle and like
dunkirk was just like it was embroiled
for sure it was just a crazy ass
excursion so i mean if you told me
you're going to see dunkirk do you think
do i think you would like it i would say
no even though i've never even seen it
okay well i'm just saying like i hope
like harry's next movie is better yeah
this seems like more in line with the
harry styles you're looking to yeah it's
it's honestly giving me like betty
draper vibes it's like this old school
like
50s thing but it's also a thriller i
have no idea what it's about it's
apparently it's a psychological thriller
which sounds good it does sound good but
i can't watch it like that why because
it's just too spooky and like there's
like shutter island shutter island i you
have to spook through right no you have
to make it through the spook yeah but
don't this movie tells the story of
alice in 1950s housewife who was living
in an experimental community with her
husband jack oh i take it back things
take a turn with when alice begins to
suspect that jack and his company are
hiding a secret
okay this sounds actually good i'm
seeing this i take it back you know what
it sounds like
um
did you ever watch lost
no oh
what's that they have this like
community what was it called
sounds like stepford wives oh such a
good movie such a good movie um
well i guess a psychological thriller i
could probably do that's like gone girl
yeah i guess and like i like books that
are thrillers i don't like horror movies
or scary movies that i don't watch
but a thriller
keeps you on the edge of your seat but i
think i'll do it okay now it's time for
tear toasters which i'm so excited about
because we had to skip last week because
jackie cause some people felt like we
had to skip it and some people felt like
we shouldn't have but here we are here
we are in the longest episode ever i
know like we really should move to
tomorrow because we don't have a lot to
talk about tomorrow because there's no
real hospitals of new york reunion on
tonight but we made a commitment and
we're doing that breaks our promise of
last week which was like we didn't do it
because it wasn't tuesday no it's
tuesday we're doing it
okay but do you think it's
dear toasters is our advice segment and
if you ever need advice write to your
toasters gmail.com and we will do our
best to get your quandary on air
first up
good morning jackie and claudia much
love to y'all my sister and i are
massive toasters and we've recently
gotten our mother to become a toaster
too she says she says with her thick
southern accent i just love to listen to
them talk that is so cute
i'm struggling with the decision and i
need your help i'm supposed to be going
on a trip to boston to visit a friend
from college in a few weeks along with a
few other people i'm usually chomping at
the bit to get on a plane and travel but
there's a small issue my ex-boyfriend we
were together for six years is one of
the people going my ex and i have
remained friends even post-breakup
because we're in the same friend group
so i sucked it up when our friends were
in town hung out with him and tried to
be as normal as possible whenever we're
in the same place he's a good guy but
he's sneaky and dishonest at times it's
why we broke up in the first place he
recently moved and for many reasons that
i don't have time to share we did not
end on good terms i've always tried to
remain positive and not badmouth him
like
not badmouth him with our other friends
for the sake of the group dynamic but
i'm thinking that a weekend getaway with
him may be too much for me to handle
i've already committed to the trip and
would love to see my friends but this
may be too much for me i just feel like
i'm always putting the group first and
never thinking about my own health and
if i don't go how the heck do i explain
to the group without blatantly saying
saying it's because of him sincerely a
loyal southern toaster that's tough and
i feel like you already know what you're
gonna do because you should not be
putting like the sake of the group like
we're adults like you have to take care
of yourself it's like the army every man
for himself it reminds me of naomi and
craig
and like how she stopped by going on the
trips and stuff like just because like i
understand like this is a group cass
ensemble but i for my own personal
mental health i can't be around my
ex-boyfriend right now i agree that
shouldn't be so confusing do what you
got to do don't worry about like the
group unless you like and it's funny
because some people would say like i
don't want to go because my boyfriend's
there but i want to go because it's
going to be a good time and i don't want
to like jeopardize i don't want to you
know
miss out and like take that away from
myself but they're going to have a
terrible time you're worried about what
they're going to think no no no stay
home say like the toe said you couldn't
go and what's worse than like spending
money on a trip where you don't have fun
like that's the most frustrating part
and you spend time away like from your
family and for me i'm like away from
theo and i'm like i'm spending money to
torture myself so if you're not thinking
in advance that you don't even think
you're gonna have fun like you
definitely should not go and i do feel
like in 2019 2018 like we did stuff like
that like yeah we went on trips we
didn't want to go on we spent money on
things we didn't want to do
and now with just like the a finite
amount of trips and and things that
we're doing like make everyone count
that's such good advice
um okay we have more deer toasters
brought to you by canva pro ever since
we found camber pro we can do anything
like a pro with any device honestly you
guys we would never admit this if we
weren't you know sponsored by camera pro
but for years our business has been run
on canva pro like everything we do is on
canva it's it's the most amazing product
everything we do is on canva like we
the redheads
is completely supported by camera built
on canvas built by canva canva pro is a
design platform that empowers you to
create and share stunning content in
just a few clicks so it's super fast and
fun you can choose from thousands of
templates that are easy to customize or
you can start from scratch they have
endless amounts of premium fonts photos
videos and so much more and they add
personality and edge to whatever you're
designing so honestly if you have like a
side business or you're an influencer
and like you're just needing cool
graphics it's the perfect place if you
don't have like tons of experience
creating content it's so easy ben
introduced it to me like years ago and
honestly our business has never been the
same like that's why we're successful
they also have a content planner you'll
save time planning creating and posting
social media content too you can pause
schedule posts edit them at any time
and it's really just like a fabulous
platform that has so many different
features and you can design with like a
pro with canva pro right now you can get
a free 45-day extended trial when you
use our promo code just go to canva.me
toast to get your free 45-day extended
trial that's
dot m-e slash toast canva.me toast all
right next your toasters
jackie and claudia
not sure if it's the three glasses of
wine talking or my period but here it
goes
i'm getting married to an absolute p
john in one month he has a close group
of friends in the city we live in most
of whom have girlfriends over the past
two years i haven't been that close to
them i don't feel like they're inclusive
but also we don't really have the same
interests i work and value my career
politics reading and they just want to
be stay-at-home moms and talk about
shopping
anyways i've been getting a little
closer to them but i still feel like i'm
an outsider i would like to do more
things with these girls but i don't
really know how to approach them any
advice would be greatly appreciated love
you both literally cried when i found
out jackie was preggy oh sincerely a
socially awkward
fomo toaster
i have to say one thing and i don't
think you're gonna like it but i do
think it's something that you need to
hear and it's just in the way that i
feel like you refer to these women so
you say you don't really know them but
like all they do is like you know shop
and like be stay-at-home moms which is
kind of condescending i'm just gonna say
but you're like into career and politics
like i feel like part of the reason why
you're not connecting with them is like
you feel like you're better than them
and like if you do feel that way then
don't hang out with them but if you do
want to get to know them if you come in
with this attitude like i don't think
it's going to be received well by them
and i'm just being honest yeah i would
say like not everyone is as they seem i
think a lot of people on the surface
seem one way and then when you take the
time to get to know them are a different
way i would also say if this is a group
of like four or five women they're all
different from one another just because
you think you might not like one of them
doesn't mean you wouldn't get along with
all of them or some of them and i think
it's not fair to loop them off i think
you are prematurely judging them a
little bit i think there's a lot of
people who yes perhaps they talk more
about like shopping and their kids
because those are like fun things to
talk about doesn't mean they don't have
political opinions or like interesting
takes on other things or things that
they're interested in that you might
find interesting yeah i feel like maybe
these people aren't that one-dimensional
yeah and i think if you it would behoove
you to become friends with your
husband's
wives like this sounds like you know
they have a group that's established and
you kind of want to come in a little bit
i would try and meet them like where
they're at it and then take it from
there but most people are not ever
exactly one thing yeah and also i feel
like maybe because you don't feel like
they've been inclusive of you you're
like a little resentful and that's why
you're coming up with these judgments so
i would just go in with like a fresh
clean slate like try not to think
anything
let them show you who they are first
before you come up and then if you don't
like them don't hang out with them but
like let them at least
be given the chance
to show you what they're all about and
all of those topics like are not
mutually exclusive
from one another right you could like
shopping and politics yeah
that's true well and career what was the
other thing that like they're
stay-at-home moms and she's more of a
career girl she's career politics and
what was reading which is a great
stay-at-home moms love to read
you don't know that they don't read like
maybe even if there's just one reader in
the group you have friend for life and
then you guys could join the redheads
like reading gorgeous reading just like
a book like reading is just like a
window into a whole new world yeah and
honestly like if you're feeling socially
awkward
i think what brings what i think will
bring you peace is like everyone is like
nobody knows how to act anymore after
the pandemic so like if you feel weird
just know like so does everyone else
yeah literally everybody is socially
awkward yeah all right here's our third
and final dear toasters girls boys
toasters please help me it's lengthy but
for the sake of a fellow toaster sanity
please ride this wave with me okay my
boyfriend is so lazy i'm begging him to
do any housework at this point he stops
every five seconds and i have to
and i have to ask him to finish the task
if and that's a huge if he even starts
one he always just says i just sat down
which must be nice because my ass cheeks
have not seen our couch since we bought
it here's small examples if he lets the
dogs out he won't get up to let them
back in if i do something i asked him to
do
sorry if i do something i asked him to
do after hours of waiting he'll say oh
big deal it was just x but it's another
added thing to my long list of to-do's
when i talk to him he sticks his tongue
out at me and makes faces i've asked him
nicely to stop and please listen to me
but he doesn't and then laughs or sings
over me he's 30 years old
i've talked to him i've written notes
i've yelled i've left i've left the mess
i begged and it's always an excuse as to
why he shouldn't do it and why i should
when i get mad about it he turns it
around on me about my attitude or my
tone he works hard at work really shines
in his career but so do a lot of people
who still clean up after themselves
we have three kids two step and his
little cousin that we raised but they
are mine in my eyes this [ __ ]
you're married
no boyfriend but so they have two step
kids and they're raising his little
cousin but she sees them all as her kids
okay okay and this matters because i
don't want to leave my family behind
because then i have no quote-unquote
rights
and we have three dogs so please
calculate that into my added stress that
does make a difference i work just
started a business and i'm an active
board member in a non-profit i'm at the
point of going insane i'm a grown woman
begging a man to clean up after himself
lastly i've tried to hire a cleaning
person before but they would have have
to come every single day to keep up with
the messes he leaves i'm [ __ ]
desperate and i can't keep yelling into
the void also i love you both oh my god
first of all like when i tell you me and
ben had
this fight last night
it's just like i come home ben works
from home and i'm out of the house for a
few hours so it's like i wake up i clean
you know i walk into the bathroom ben
left his underwear and i hang up the
towel and he let the q-tips open so it's
just little things i go into the kitchen
he left his eggs like a little thing i
go to the toast i come back and it's
like it's all been undone and there's
boxes open now because he got you know
work for spritz like and yesterday i had
a boiling point and i guess i didn't
realize like all day when i was talking
to him i was just bitching at him like
take the boxes out yeah we need more
garbage bags and when he got into bed he
was like you have been such like a [ __ ]
to me all day and i'm like okay i can
acknowledge that like i've definitely
been nasty for sure but can you
acknowledge that it's because like all i
do is pick up after you and it's
starting to eat away at me yeah
and he's like but i'm so busy and i'm
like so am i like being busy doesn't
mean you can't clean and i'm not asking
you to shine your shoes and scrub the
floors just like when you finish
something like put it in the trash like
it's so basic we literally had this
argument last night and honestly
it's still left unresolved like this
morning like we were still not talking
we have had this argument too
but i feel like zach is like a neat
freak no
no that's a common misconception
i actually know you're right comments
when we travel together he's not a claim
for you no and he doesn't need anything
he's not a helper no he's not he's not a
raise my hand oh [ __ ] you want me to do
the dishes i got this no and if i ask
him to do the dishes he says yes and
then two hours later i come out they're
still not done
he will do the dishes between now and
the time he dies
literally and when i say like can you
take the trash out i mean
now
i have to say can you please do the
dishes in the next hour that way the
next time i come out here like they
aren't like you have to put parameters
but honestly and i find it so
infuriating and we've had some i've
knocked down
a fever pitch at some points where it's
like you know what it is it's [ __ ]
it's insulting and it's disrespectful
that's what i say so are you leaving
this
that's exactly i'd literally say first
of all you're disrespecting our home
and you're disrespecting me because
you're obviously not going to pick up
your socks that you leave assuming that
it's going to be me and honestly it
offends me it's offensive it's it's so
offensive and it's disrespectful and so
i'm saying like i i understand this
feeling yet what you've described is so
much worse
i agree like the way he's reacting to
the sticking out his tongue like a child
like when before you said that you guys
had like a family together i was like
girl leave this grown up right right
right that's why i needed to clarify
because i thought that she had said
boyfriend but it's obviously you guys
are much more their family partners in
life so if she listens in like a
six-month relationship they're her step
kids so they're his biological kids and
then the third child is a cousin of his
that they're raising so she would have
no right
breaking up of a family like and you
don't do that just because your
boyfriend didn't you know take the dogs
back so we have to make this work we
have to we do have to make that and it's
it's in the communication i it's in the
communication but no like you seem
like you seem like you've tried every
avenue and like now you're coming to us
and i think you touched on something one
that he's very successful in his career
which is which is good like he's doing
something yeah and two that you've tried
a cleaning lady but that or i'm sorry
man or lady and but that person would
have to come every single day it's not
sustainable he should be if he doesn't
want to do his share yeah he should be
paying for a housekeeper every single
day i think that's a great conversation
you should tell him that and you should
say like this will alleviate so much of
the things that are coming between us
and we should try it no but i know what
she's saying like even if you have a
housekeeper come every day like your
husband gets home from work and he shits
up the place like it it's such a
character flaw and honestly even though
i think like a housekeeper would make a
big difference
we're adults and like we have to learn
how to clean up after ourselves and i
don't think that like this band-aid is
gonna
i know i know i just like i it's a
character i like hate to like give the
false hope that like people can change
and you sometimes just have to like
consider where they are in their
immaturity
and like
i do think people can change in this
sense because from it's it's not great
now with ben but from when i first met
him it is leaps and bounds better like
he wouldn't even put the clothes in the
hamper like just leave them on the floor
and i'm like come on this is not a barn
it's true so he is still not perfect
but he has made enormous strides like i
would be remiss devastated and
heartbroken if i didn't at least
acknowledge how much of a difference
like he used to really like not even
know how to fold a shirt and watching
him was like actually i wanted to gouge
my eyes out now is it a great shirt fold
no but he knows how to do it so okay
okay there's hope improvement can be
made but this guy it's not even so much
his cleaning that's the problem it's his
attitude reality yeah yeah okay well
then maybe you need to find what does he
have what are his gripes with you what
are things that he asks you to do like
you hold out on those things until he
does the things that you need him to do
or if the couch is like his favorite
place and that's where he mostly hangs
out you don't really hang out there like
everything that he leaves on the floor
and around the house i love doing that
put it on the couch i love doing dirty
pants
on the couch you're just like you can't
care about the couch right like ketchup
i've never done that oh no i don't do
with stuff i do like there's so much
clothing on the floor i put all of it on
men's pillow like
like then he'll notice like finally yeah
yeah wait but really quickly
there's also one thing here's the thing
put the dirty pan on his pillow you know
by the somewhere that they can't ignore
it like somehow i've actually put like
ben's sneakers like
on his pillow
just like so it's in his face but also
there might be one other thing at play
here like she said he's successful in
his job like he just might be like a
chauvinist who thinks that like a woman
cleans if he earns a living so like i
just need more information like do you
work like is that the arrangement he
thinks he's in
interest and that's why he's blowing you
off
he's like
i went to work today you clean the house
i feel like she would have said that
yeah so i feel like now i feel like no
also
but it's just it's worth throwing out
there yeah no i this is honestly this is
something i would write into a podcast
about like i'm struggling with this i
think solution is pan on pillow
but then like you have to sleep next to
that smelly pants i know
again you're tortured no and it's like
my happiness constantly being sacrificed
[ __ ] you guys i'm sure this is like a
very universal issue
please share like in the comments or
whatever
what you what your advice is here
or what the most annoying thing your
boyfriend or partner does because for me
like ben because he walks theo he wears
the crocs and he leaves the crocs out in
the hallway and it's just like they're
just stained like our neighbors what
they must think of us crocs like yeah
it's ben uses our hallway like it's just
crocks or because they're in the hallway
it's both the crocs are embarrassing and
not only are their crocs they're furry
on the inside and tie-dye rainbow on the
outside okay but also ben leaves his
golf clubs out there he leaves theo's
leash out there he has boxes out there
that's a storage unit yeah it's so
embarrassing that is bad so that's like
my personal vendetta like pet peeve of
what ben does my personal actually
wait i might have the solution my
personal thing has always been like
zach's eggy pan oh my god
he thinks if it like if sometimes you
have to leave a dish in this thing to
let it soak in the in the soap oh by the
way do not tell them that because that
bed then we'll literally put a fork in
there like it's soaking
he leaves it on the stove so obviously
like sometimes you do have to do like i
don't know if he's airing it but they
use that excuse but it's so barely like
left there for me it's so offensive but
ever since i've been pregnant you guys
know i can't stand the kitchen smell i
can't be in the kitchen i can't even do
my own dishes because i need to get in
and out of the kitchen as soon as
possible and so in exchange for carrying
his child yep he has to do all of my
dishes and he's been doing them that's
the solution go off birth control like
that is the solution mm-hmm and then you
can just like and i this is a real thing
for me like and it's annoying like i
have to leave a big mess and then i have
to you know i can't just like i guess i
could
no but you know what's so fresh like it
really grosses me out so he has taken
that up for me
and that's why this hasn't been an issue
for a few months okay but see the thing
is and i think this is what i fear it's
like okay so let's say i get ben to do
all the chores like he does them so
poorly like i might as well just do them
myself like i agree with you so it
bothers me like he makes the bed and you
jackie you would die like lumpy at lumps
everywhere
i'll just [ __ ] do it myself i don't
even know what it looks like for his
acting for that oh what he's meant made
badly yeah no i feel that but like if he
like ben is just not even good at the
chore so it's like
okay yeah i want you to do it out of
respect like honestly like you do it so
badly like yeah but like putting a dish
in the dishwasher is not that's true
that's true but he then puts the dirty
knife back into the
the ben loves to do that
i'm talking about ben yeah if he cuts
like bread or something that's not wet
use knives yeah right it's just his
hands he just uses suppose
he just uses his fingers to order
postmates no if ben cuts something and
it's not like super wet ben's a chef all
if it's not super like if it's bread
he'll put the knife back in the cutting
thing um honestly if it's like butter
he'll just like wipe it off but if it's
like you know something really like a
tomato yeah no that's goes in the sink
yeah but like you are you're not
supposed to wash your knives but you are
just supposed to
no you're not supposed to put them in
the dishwasher
it's bad for the knife that's news to me
right so he's like but you do you should
run it under the sink and then wipe it
with a towel whatever all i'm saying is
that this is a universal problem and if
you guys could just like let us know
what your solutions are like because
we're both in need of help we are all we
all are in need of help literally so
that was dear toasters again if you ever
want to write in it's deartoasters
gmail.com and if you have an update for
us and we've read one of your queries on
air recently and you want to let us know
how it went also write us dear toasters
gmail.com we would love to hear you and
that is our show the longest show ever
ever i hope you guys enjoy it i hope you
have an amazing day and thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
monday morning show where we deliver the
fast life stories that you need to know
everybody friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcasts anywhere podcasts can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast blocks all the
places where you listen to the podcast
five nice morning shows leave the five
star of you about beautiful stunning and
smart we are if you made it here
congratulations you are part of the
society season two and to let us know
that you made it egg in the pan emoji
use the egg or the pan emoji on our most
recent instagram to let us know that you
are a part of the society have an
amazing day you guys we'll see you
tomorrow bye